now what did you have there looks like
you got the beats that what do you mean
what do you see that one side is playing
on one side it looks like prosciutto
with mushrooms yeah prosciutto and it
was no it was like a sun-dried tomato
favorite I can eat pizza like for lunch
dinner and breakfast produces market
this is fantastic
are you good can you cook pizza I'm a
pizza really yeah I love it so diverse
great fun and you seem like you're
enjoying that you had a whole wedge in
your mouth at any one time yeah you
haven't heard of a knife knife and fork
no you just pick it up and stick it in
he's English somebody told me if a bear
ever attacks you all you have to do is
pinch his nipples is this true or did
you not know that do you know first of
all is the most brilliant thing in the
world
sorry for it you have the softest skin I
can't believe this is our first time
meeting I couldn't imagine our next time
and personally I am of course in spite
of appearances I'm a heterosexual man
congratulations and the people think
because I'm so well-dressed people drink
he must be gay no no though look he's
wonderful haircut he must be gay look
how sensitive and vulnerable you must be
gay that means women feel safe around me
they trust me then bang pregnant bang
pregnant bang pregnant
yes you did scare us from your sorry ass
kangoo scream like that in real life you
know well you would never know let me
ask you you can only you can only wear
that if he has been lovely the lovely
well-shaped of muscular lengthy lovely
legs now what is that it like are we
wearing culottes or what are you sure
it's George's hot up yeah is it really
hot out there actually we get you know
it's that wonderful springtime in New
York nice to see you again how you doing
I'm really good yeah you I'm fantastic
thank you I saw this movie the other day
the break-up guy that was a you know
you're just a when you see on the screen
you're just as lovely on the screen as
you are here but you're bigger on the
screen and and and bigger and loveliness
is always exactly what you're looking
for what am i saying what am I talking
about don't think about what I'm wearing
these things are okay you're touching
that is the sub nothing to you how long
is this this show yeah I just kind of
want to know how long it is it's over I
felt bad because I knew I was not gonna
be able to eat that bread on till next
year
really so how much how much weight did
you gain did you get
what question is that I'm not gonna say
like two pounds no like ten pounds
whatever
well how many similar give I don't know
dude the Internet's too [ __ ] weird to
give out all that information
oh you don't even want to say how many
because you're afraid that it was yeah
my all be Mike you're talking about it
is anybody can hunt this out I'm honest
dude like there's yeah no dude I yeah
this [ __ ] lunatics out there okay
well off the air off the year geez I
love how surprised to you well if you
can imagine the amount when you do this
fox show if it is successful are you
gonna change I'm not gonna change yeah
are you gonna be the same day you are
now the humble guy I'm gonna be the same
dirty son of a [ __ ] as I am now right
thank you this is live tonight we
appreciate that's nice that's not
swearing oh no of course not no that's
just I think that's part of it Fox I'm
gonna see that and stand over our we
know we're not gonna hire my son is a
very good coach can you change the name
ma what no Manoah what does it mean
Hispanic name you should everything
needs a meaning oh really yeah that's
correct right sounds like a paint um
okay this is my interview yeah
III won once time one time I kissed
relic
yeah we on a ferry or no that Indian guy
from the show gave me some bad heroin
that's not true no that part up but I
did have a long kiss with relic the
aliens can communicate messages to us
through our hair so I thought take that
to its natural conclusion try and reach
out to them a little bit it's not all
one-way traffic
well that's right I think you're doing
us a favor perhaps I might be I've not
received any signals as yet Dave it's
rather than a very clear one from humans
of get your haircuts before adrienne
before we break for a commercial
[Applause]
oh okay look at it he got by me Maxima
that's not my Lake now you know listen I
get what you're saying we say breakout
role but I feel like you know there's
been times I think it was a breakout
role for sure yeah you know listen end
of the day this is what makes me maybe
maybe coming into the data super MASINT
know you got different types of men you
got soldiers and you got tanks I'm the
one that's shooting a bullet
yes I'm saying I think that you love me
cuz every time we fight as I'm driving
home I get a text from you that says you
know I love you right
oh my god yeah I love you is it me yeah
he's our boy Oh baby
so you're like half and half you like it
all the way don't you so you were there
filled your cover with half a happen oh
I know it's television
what are you are the only person ever in
the my career here to get that close to
my face easy honors I like it that car
you very base to know so does that mean
it doesn't matter yes yes yes working
out those things it doesn't feel like it
is No yeah your energy is like it's a
little too strong I have a legit job
yes going really good really yeah how
long have you been together four years
and its strong it's really sure yeah and
she's way better than you
all right let me take care I'll take
care this hand me that card gives that
Kurtz I'm becoming
[Applause]
[Applause]
you think about that when you and your
little friend in the Knicks outfit are
getting in a cab later okay
[Applause]
yeah okay Russell respected the table
and Jenga he's like your desk is a
puzzle it is I'm sorry about that I
think we're gonna be careful okay sorry
okay
I'm gonna have some blood I've got
instinct I've actually had a baby
delivered at my show a lady's water
broke there you know hold baby or cut
the umbilical cord yourself baptize the
baby you back to a site with morning do
you carry holy water is that sunshine
you spit I'm an angel
so it's over oh that's that would make
sense boom thank you Jesus
quietly their face while they're doing
facebooking facebooking yeah yeah
shopping okay they can look at
pornography a face block tomorrow I
don't know I don't know you did say you
were just cross well I don't know we
might get in trouble if I say this I
called the guy black I don't know if you
can say that he's black yeah bye say hey
the black guys cheating and they're like
you can't say that I was like why I
don't know his name and then I can't
Saints Wendell I go okay hey Wendell the
gay guy says I can't call you the black
guy but I'm sure we can go for it give
us a little nipple actually Kevin before
you sit down can we just get him a
little bump let's tell them up what's
that try to further framing we need to
push it up you're too small for the just
paying a camera down I don't need to
send the booster seat Thank You moose
I'm not sitting the booster seat what is
it apricot I think I take it I think I
opened oh hang it oh okay
I take it just cuz I want to snack and
got new job
what are you doing is this a bit breast
man are you a bottle man where we uh so
ride-along hey can we get you having a
quick change it smells like you made a
little bit of a boom boom just let's
just change the style Cisco I think I
think you guys are confusing a short man
for reform baby get him something eaters
hey it seems like he's just kind of
acting up hey hey okay hey I'm not no
[ __ ] baby of short stature that does
not mean I'm a baby
how many keys on it
hey just tell me how many keys let me
see it man where you go you doing
troublemaker will honk no I made shovel
make it man doesn't about me dude
I chemistry first of all this this good
having anyone just hold on a second
there we go I just want to make sure
that you don't fall back and hit your
soft spot man if you don't get your hand
off my [ __ ] head here's the number
one rule in Hollywood don't work with no
animals don't work with no kids I did
all we there yet and there are ten times
more professional than this one you got
you know what you got another thing
coming what was it like working together
on ride-alongs temper tantrums you know
I'm saying
crayons all over the Jews because I like
to draw you know I'm saying just little
baby bull I don't know if we could do
that no